WASH THIS SEASON, GIVING UPMPNYF
LAST SEASON, SWINGING IT AROUNDE
WITHOUT A SCORING CHANCE,
IMMEDIATELY.
THAT
NHL DEBUT THIS SEASON, TIED WITH
SAN JOSE FOR MOST IN THE IS SHE.
AND FED NICELY ACROSS
THE LAST IN 59
ALREADY GOT ONE TONIGHT AND NOW
SEIDER, DeKEYSER, THERE IS A
SHOT.
MAY NOT KNOW
WHEN KIDS CLUB.
MICKEY: AND HIS LINE MATE HAVING
SCORED FIVE GOALS THE LAST TIME
THAT HE HAD TAKEN BY RASMUSSEN,E
FOR
IS INTERCEPTED THAT TIME AND THS
ARE FIRING THE
HIS S IS STITCHED
AROUND TO -- TIPPED AROUND TAKE.
HAVE YOU SEEN HIM?
CONGRATULATIONS, MAN,,
A SAVE MADE UP BY SEIDER.
HE RUSHED SHIFT.
KE
AND RIGHT FOOT, REGAINED RED WIT
PASS.
OSHIE  OVECHKIN BUT THAT PUCK
JUST FOUND ITS WAY INTO ON THATh
ERNE, BERTUZZI, LETTING IT GO.
CARLSON FOR WASHINGTON.
MICKEY: OH, THEY
AWAY, 3-1.
MICKEY: WHA